a mãe do pobre brigando em casa ela ela
começa brigando com você depois ela já
tá nos assuntos que não tem nada a ver o
pobre do pai não tem nada a ver com
assunto ela mete o pai no meio tava
brigando na escola né gaz ficou sabendo
disso Ton ficou sabendo que o gaz estava
brigando na escola tu não faz merda
nenhuma essa família do teu pai não ser
para [__] nenhuma aqui na casa do pobre
quem fala é a mãe a mãe grita a mãe fala
tudo e o pai é o Marrone da relação é o
Marrone Você tem para quem puxar é pra
família do teu pai esses bosta Olha eu
não sei para que que eu casei sair de
casa foi logo para sair de casa eu tô
doidinha a minha cabeça tá doendo eu tô
é tonta aí quando terminar lavar sai sai
da mesa deixa o prato na mesa gle gleon
vai deixar o prato fala com o menino Ant
tu não faz bosta nenhuma tu e merda é a
mesma coisa